mandam used to turn it into a game black
growing up it was people like oh like
you know the whole mr stewie or girl
like stuff like that yeah
i remember a person who remained
nameless
they were out
and then
they secured the girl on the night out
or the lady i should say and gone to the
car
she's glugging him off doing the throat
go business in the car
um
the husband's called it's just like i'll
pick you up
she's finished off
the guy and then she's got and picked up
by a matey wow and she drove home she's
happy satisfied
this is crazy
oh my god women are
interesting do you think man cheat as
bad
not as bad because men are sloppy like
if your man's cheating you probably know
that's bad deep down you probably know
that he's cheating yeah that women
always have a hunch exactly i would
agree with that yeah would you would you
guys be willing to share a guy
if if he had everything you wanted he
loved you
but just now and then he would step out
just arrives
look at it look at it
man me and jess are on a two-for-one
special
get it while you can yes sister wives
would you actually do that
no no no
no
you might i might okay why tell me why i
don't
i think monogamy is very hard
i think long term man and women so would
you took an open relationship are you
talking about on his end
um
it would have to be both oh it would
have to be oh
yeah
it would have to be so we're still love
sorry to cut you off go go go go
could you still
because a lot a man we've had the
conversation before a man can love a
woman and throws willie around and fall
into vagina from time to time but a lot
of women they can't do that so would you
could you say that you could still love
the guy you're with and still be open in
a relationship in my mind
i think after a certain amount of years
5 10 maybe 20 years yes
in the beginning early phases i don't
think
i could because that possessive like
need to claim is there but i think
eventually i imagine this is how i
imagine after time
i probably could i would probably be a
bit bored i imagine he would too would
you be willing to do it where it's it's
open on his end but not yours no i feel
like that's what the terms would usually
be if he's providing and stuff like that
yeah if he's providing okay so if he's
taking how many relationships are like
just the man providing
no but this is isn't that the scenario
you presented oh yeah yeah yeah so he's
if he's providing well then yeah i'd
probably have to put up with it but yeah
you like see no evil
fun fact 8 000 years ago 17 women
reproduced for every one man
yeah so we can't we can't do biology
8 000 years ago 17 women reproduced for
every one man that's a football team in
the suburbs wow so then did the man want
to go back in time but now
with the population getting so out of
control surely it would make sense to
reverse that
so so actually there's there's um
there's probably going to be problems in
society because of population decline
actually people aren't having kids
why because okay think about it um
if you don't have enough people in the
next generation to fill jobs
then that leaves a gap in society
what jobs are not being filled well
right now um i want to say the medical
industry is low on like doctors and i
don't know specifically i just know that
one of the biggest like causes of
civilizations like collapsing as a
population decline
when you think about yeah like
overpopulation is good for an economy
yeah when you look at um japan because
they've got an aging population they've
got to a point of because they've got um
less young staff coming in to work
they've got state funded uh fueled
pensions but there's so many pensioners
and there's not enough workforce oh okay
so you've just got a lot of people
living in the state and not enough
people paying into the state
so why are young people not going into
the workplace what is that no it's just
people don't have having kids
yeah why are they not having kids they
can't afford it they don't
so um i would say it's because of
hypergamy do you know what hypergamy is
so hypergamy is the action of marrying
or forming a sexual relationship with a
person of a superior sociological or
educational background women date across
and up hierarchies
so essentially when birth control was
introduced it gave women the option to
sleep around
so when that happened basically a
smaller and smaller percentage of men
were sleeping with all the girls so if
you ask a hundred percent of women what
they want in a guy they list 20 percent
of men sometimes less so if you want a
guy that's over six foot that's only
fifteen percent of guys
you wanna be good looking cut it in half
you want them to make money cut that in
half right so basically when that
happened um i think it let fours fives
and sixes in terms of like looks sleep
with guys that are eights nines and tens
and think they're on that level and then
think anything below it is settling
okay
so as women's rights and freedom have
progressed relationships have regressed
yes
so
yeah yeah we need to either
step down
how do we get out of this
everyone needs to start having children
yeah okay i mean i think it's just
like we're just in a society where women
a lot of women are delusional okay
because what's your level right anyone's
like level one to ten it's what you can
get to commit to you it's not what you
can sleep with
and i think a lot of times women like
confuse the two
and so they'll they'll [ __ ] on average
men
like like that's why we have in society
we have
i don't want no scrub like
[Laughter]
but we don't have i don't want no whales
i don't want no fat chicks like they
would be canceled immediately
and so everything in society it's weird
once you see it you can't unsee it it's
like everything in society is empowering
woman and pushing women forward and so
it it makes us narcissistic almost
because we think the whole world
revolves around us
but the same thing of what empowers you
also makes you blind because even though
you think you're being empowered but
then when you're not getting wifed by
the man that you want and he goes into
the real wild world and he realized i'm
actually very regular regular i'm
nothing special
okay
but what class of women are you talking
about like how intellectual are they
where do they come from what are women
or you think all women think like this
most women yeah
would you think they think they're about
i think they should yeah because you get
the dating app data which allows women
to be very honest and women only swipe
right five percent of the time
they're not ugly in pictures though no
women find 80 no no women find 80 of men
unattractive not
okay like unattractive but what about in
person no just anywhere anywhere yeah
eighty percent of men they find
unattractive but because i've spoken to
them or because on face value they like
there's something chemically that
they're like because they've had better
sexually and they're just their
standards are skewed
yeah so a lot of a lot of times i'll
hear girls say things like oh he's
medium ugly and i'm like no sis that's
your level
but but you know that term you've heard
it right
oh you've never heard me you're not on
social media right yeah i'm snapchat
because only 20 of men are actually
having sex
20 yeah so one out of one out of three
men either are virgins or haven't had
sex in the past year and that's the
trend so that's the trend that's going
on the last like 50 years where it's
like 50 years yes slowly it's a bigger
and bigger percentage of men aren't
having sex so but if most women are
having sex that means they're having sex
with the same guys
that's like why do you think women say
things like men are trash all men cheat
dead
because we're all